[Music]
hello and welcome to this webinar
so um i will explain how we use the
tumor max media to generate primary cell
cultures and
derive cell lines from this i will start
with a short introduction on two more
models in general
and then also explain the workflow that
we used
and then give you some exemplary data
and explain a few details
about the two muscle lines and cultures
that we generate
so let's take a look at the different
tumor models that you can use in
cancer research and pre-clinical testing
so you see an overview of different
models and um
of course there are some quite exotic
ones like the zebrafish which is
also quite commonly used these days
but i think the most important models
that you can see here
are on the one hand the in vitro models
that we have so 2d
and 3d cultures and then of course we
also have the xenograph models so in
vivo models that you can use for more
complex
essays and studies that you want to do
so the in vitro models um you have
cell lines 2d cell lines that you can
order and simply put them in a dish and
they will grow
so they are quite easy to propagate and
of course since they just grow in a dish
you can easily manipulate them and add
compounds and do
testing or whatever you want to do with
them and
basically you only need a cell culture
lab to run
in vitro tests for the xenograph models
these are mainly used when you have more
complex testing of course because
you have tissues so organs more or less
growing in a
mouse and you can do studies like
biodistribution
and more complex readouts because the
tumors that will grow in a mouse
will more closely resemble the patient
two more
on the other hand growing tumors in mice
is quite expensive because
mice themselves are not too cheap you
need the facilities and ethic approvals
and of course you need all the
infrastructure for maintaining
immunodeficient mice and one quite
important aspect at least when we talk
about pdx models or patient-derived
xenografts
you graft pieces of tumor tissue into an
animal
and if you want to expand it so if you
want to generate more of this tissue in
order to run
larger cohorts for your testing this
always means that you have to expand the
the tissue on animals which is quite
costly and
something to consider
when we now take a closer look on in
vitro models
you see the division so it's a table
here and we divided them into
the traditional or classical cell lines
so like hela cells
or mcf7 cells that you can simply order
on from different vendors and then we
have the primary cell lines on the very
right hand side so cells that you can
passage and cryopreserve and so on
but also more short termed cell cultures
and when we first take a look at the
traditional cell lines of course you see
hundreds of papers on what they can do
and cannot do what they express and what
has been tested on them
so they are very well characterized and
studied
when you look at primary cell cultures
or cell lines so primary cells derived
from patient tissues
of course they have all the
patient-specific features and mutations
which can be an advantage if you want to
look more into detail in personal
medicine for example
but on the other hand of course this
means that whenever you set up a model
using primary cells
you have to individually characterize
the cells and the model that you are
using
when we now look at in v in vivo models
that you could generate from cell lines
when you look at the traditional ones
of course these cells have been passage
for
hundreds of passages already in vitro
so the cells that you have are quite
homogeneous
once you inject them into mice they will
also form quite homogeneous
xenograft models upon this extensive
propagation in vitro they might
lose some tumor initiating capacity and
due to these homogeneous tumors that
they form in vivo
of course the the recapitulation of
patient tumors is quite limited so they
do not really look like patient tumors
when we now look at primary cells since
they
keep all the patient-specific features
they also
keep their patient specific subtypes of
tumor cells so
they really recapture recapitulate
the patient to my heterogeneity they
preserve tumor initiating
capacity so that means you can always
also generate in vivo
xenograft models from the tumors or to
muscle lines that you have
which is not always true for classical
cell lines
and again they keep all the
patient-specific features which
is a plus when you look at personalized
medicine but of course
you have to characterize them first
then finally when you look at the more
technical aspects traditional cell lines
are really easy to
get you can simply order them from
different vendors you order them you put
them in culture
and you're almost good to go for your in
vitro testing
the media that i use are quite simple so
you have a
quite simple bass laser medium like rpmi
or dmem
and you add serum 10 or 20
which makes it quite inexpensive and
easy to
generate but of course serum is largely
undefined
and you you don't really know what you
put into your in vitro model when you
add serum
on the other hand you can just passage
them for
hundreds of passages and they will still
grow and you can
still do your in vitro testing now when
we look at the primary cells again
you can't just order them anywhere you
need access to primary
biopsies of course usually from
hospitals you need to get them you need
patient content so it's a little bit
more complicated
and then also when you want to use media
there's
only a limited amount of off the shelf
media so
this basically means that um you can
either
start developing your own homebrew
medium but
then you need to test different
concentrations of cytokines and growth
factors
not only for one tumor entity so once
you have
a medium that works good for one tumor
entity you basically have to change
a lot of things to make it work for
another tumor entity as well
and then as briefly mentioned in the
beginning the primary cell cultures
you can put cells in culture they will
adhere and
you can keep them for up to four weeks
less
let's say but for some patients the
cells simply stop growing stop
proliferating
and uh this leaves you with a time frame
of two to four weeks to perform your in
vitro essays
whereas when you have cells that do not
stop uh proliferating
you uh can actually treat them like
traditional cell lines so passage them
over and over
and yeah have an individual model that
you can just cryo preserve
and for whenever you need it so let's
continue with
the workflow so of course when you want
to generate your own cenline you start
with a solid
tissue biopsy and you need some material
to start your cell lines
we have this optimized workflow so we
start with a solid
with a solid tumor and at least in our
case
um we mainly get them from hospitals so
they need to be
shipped overnight and we have the mux
tissue storage solution to
also store uh the cells overnight during
the transport
from this we take the tumor biopsy the
solid biopsy out of the
transport medium so to say and perform
tissue dissociation with the gentlemax
octo and our tumor dissociation kit
human in this case
and um this is followed then so we get a
single cell suspension
and then isolate two more cells so when
we have
primary patient tumors it's of course a
tumor cell isolation kit human
but when we talk about xenografts you
have
mouse host cells contaminating your
tumor cells
so we use the mouse cell depletion kit
and
this is then followed by just taking the
cells that you isolated
and resuspend them in two more max media
and grow your cell lines after the
dissociation or also after cell
isolation
we phenotype the cells and
it's also not a bad idea to also
phenotype
a cell line once in a while to see
whether there are some changes or
something that
is not really expected so this is of
course done with flow cytometry because
it's quite easy
and for this we have the cytometers and
the antibodies
so this workflow we don't always
just follow this workflow and always
work with isolated tumor cells
the transport medium we've seen in the
past that
um during the transport there are also
some cells released from the
solid tumor biopsy so what we tend to do
is to just take the transportation
medium spin it down
and when you see a nice pellet you know
that you have a lot of tumor cells
and also other cells in there and we
simply resource paint the pellet and
tumor max media and also
use this as material to start the
culture
and the same is also true for the tumor
dissociation
when you choose conditions where the
tissue is not completely digested but
after finishing the program on the
device you may have some
some chunks of tissue and want to go for
explant cultures
we've seen that it's advantageous to
take these
pieces or chunks of tissue after
dissociation when you filter
the cell suspension and just pick up the
pieces from
the filter that you use and also
resuspend them in tumor max media
and grow grow your cells so this leaves
us with
actually isolated tumor cells so this
would be one kind of starting material
then the chunks of the dissociation the
second
type of material that we use and then
also the cells that we can recover from
the transportation medium
so this is the basic workflow that we
that we use
i'd like to give you some information on
the different
parts of the workflow so first of all
the tissue storage
solution this is as i said just a
transportation medium
and it has been optimized to
store tissues for up to 48 hours
so whenever the shipment takes longer
than 24 hours or
even just overnight we've validated up
to 48 hours
and we know that as you can see down
here the cell viability is preserved
during that time
um we always used fresh tissue to
compare it to so
freshly dissociated tissue and then
either started for 24 hours or 48 hours
and as you can see
the viability viability is preserved
one other quite important aspect
about the tissue storage solution is
that it does not contain
any harmful agents so nothing to fix
cells so it's
compatible with any downstream
application for that require
requires viable cells for the tissue
dissociation
i briefly mentioned the gentlemax octo
you see it down
here it's a fully automated system so
once you put the tube with the tissue
and the enzyme mix on the device you can
press play and
walk away so of course this is more a
user independent
we have eight individual positions on
the device so you can
run eight different samples or eight
different tissues even
and have a quite parallelized workflow
and the whole system is closed which is
very important when you use
human material because it's user safe
then we have the the enzyme mixes so the
tumor dissociation kits which are
optimized for
tumor biopsies and we use highly pure
enzymes for purified enzymes that
ensure a lot to lot consistency and
always the same activity that you use in
your dissociation
so there's nothing you need to be afraid
of when you're using your lot it's
the same activity no side effects or
side
activity and it's quite standardized the
cell viability of course is preserved
because we want to
recover viable cell suspensions to do
some downstream
experiments and then also keyobitomes
are
preserved we have for both both of the
tumor
dissociation kits so for human and for
mouse we have whole lists of
epitopes that we tested for stability so
you can always check whether the epitope
you want to look at
downstream is preserved or there's one
component that you might want to
reduce and then preserve the epitope but
everything is written in the datasheet
just
one more aspect about tumor dissociation
so
we've heard quite often so when you look
at tumors of course
there are also blood derived cells so
two more infiltrating cells in the
tissue and
um you might think okay they are
infiltrated from blood vessels and they
are not really
toughly connected uh within the tissue
uh
and that's where we wanted to check for
um
for this so you could things when
they're just like loosely lying in the
tissue
you don't have to use enzymes but uh we
compared this uh in this case for a
mouse tumor
you see that association with enzymes
and without enzymes
and we looked at uh t cells so tim3 p1
positive ones or like three
p one positive ones and as you can see
although they
should not really be um sticking to
other cells within the tissue
you do not recover them if you do not
use enzymes at all and just focus on the
mechanical
dissociation whereas when you use
enzymes of course they support the whole
dissociation process and you yield a lot
of t cells
so um from the tumor dissociation um
i mentioned the the two muscle isolation
and there are actually three different
scenarios you can
think of when you have human tumor
biopsies you have human cells growing in
a human so the biopsy contains
tumor cells after a tissue dissociation
the single cell suspension is then
isolated using the two muscle isolation
kit human
which will label the human non-tumor
cells and remove them
when you when we talk about human
xenotransplanted
tissue so you have human tumor cells
growing in a mouse
it's still more or less a human tumor so
we use the human tumor dissociation kit
but when we want to isolate tumor cells
we use the mouse cell depletion kit
which labels all the
host derived non-tumor cells and removes
them
and of course the third situation when
you work with
mass models in genetic mass models are
genetically induced once
you have mouse cells growing in a mouse
but we won't focus on this
in the webinar of today the tumor
isolation kits that we developed
um all rely on labeling the non-tumor
cells
so no matter what kind of tumor you're
working with you do not know
uh you do not have to know specifically
about the markers that are expressed in
order
to enrich the cells that you want you
can rather just remove the cells you do
not want so
um it's quite easy and applicable for a
wide range of tumors
but at the same times the cells that you
cover and that you want to isolate they
are free of
any beads and free of any labels so
you can perform another
magnetically um magnetic cell separation
or um also since there are no labels on
the cells you can also
do any kind of phenotyping and do not
worry about any uh
issues with block epitopes or something
like that so
you recover beat free labor-free highly
pure tumor cells
and all these kits have also been tested
on the auto mix so
automation is also possible for those
three kids
now a few examples for isolation of
tumor cells the first example is a human
tumor
it's actually a pleural effusion that we
received from
an ovarian cancer patient and before the
isolation so the bulk
material so to say as you can see here
only contains
a small fraction of epithelial tumor
cells expressing
epchem we use for example cd31 to stain
endothelial cells or
in this plot cd45 to stain
leukocytes and you see that there is
quite some contamination here
when we use the tumor cell isolation kit
although it's not a solid tumor
in this case you can still use the kit
and isolate highly enrich
the the tumor cells so you see
a highly pure population of epem
expressing cells
without any remaining endothelial or
blood cells this also thinks culture
so of course you can put the plural
effusion as it is
just spin it down we suspend it into max
medium
but as you can see here this is the
original fraction
you see some tumor cells that attached
but when you take a closer look
you see lots of debris and there are
some areas here that
um the tumor cells can attach basically
because the debris is lying
under it so it's also in many cases also
advised to first perform tumor cell
isolation as you can see here
you end up with really high highly pure
cultures of tumor cells
um hardly any debris and unhardly any
unwanted cells
the next example is the mass cell
depletion kit you just
see the principle up here so all
host derived so mouse non tumor cells
are labeled with beads
the tumor cells so your cells of
interest
do not get a label so the negative
fraction
the antac touch fraction contains the
tumor cells
and you can also if you want to elude
the positive fractions or the mouse
cells
in case you have any downstream
application where this is important
and you see the the staining here so you
see a small fraction of epchem
expressing cells before the isolation
you see all the host derived mouse cells
down here
after the isolation you have a pure
population of human tumor cells
and if you need them and want them you
can also isolate the mouse cells
that you see down here and also do
downstream applications with those
we also have some examples of cultures
here so when you just play the
bulk cells after dissociation
you see that you grow some human tumor
cells we stamped them with a
human-specific
antibody in green here and
but you also see and this was taken
after five days
that you have a lot of mouth cells in
this case we used a
vimetin antibody for the mouse drama
cells and
you can imagine if you leave these cells
for another five days for example
you will end up with mostly two mouse
cells and
the precious tumor cells are gone if you
just isolate the tumor cells you see
that you have highly pure cultures of
tumor cells and you can hardly find
some stromal cells in there so this is a
good way to save your
tumor cells from being overgrown by
non target cells let's finally take a
look at the
tumor max media themselves so the first
important part
you should notice is that the tumor
tumor max media are tumors
tumor type specific so we've already
released a pancreas ovarian and renal
specific medium
and the colon specific medium will be
released in q4
this year and we're working on more to
more max media as i said initially you
need to
optimize the composition of growth
factors and cytokines for
each and every two more cell type and
we've done this
so this is something you can buy off the
shelf and use for your specific tumor
cells
they do not contain serum so this means
that they will not really support the
growth of
fibroblasts and they are defined so we
do not have
theorem and we really know what's in
there and can use those media
by choosing the right growth factors for
the specific
tumor subtypes they also specifically as
for the growth of tumor cells
so we have optimized those
media for supporting the growth of cells
directly derived from from primary
tissues so from solid tumor biopsies
they are not optimized for growing mcf7
or something like this in those media
they are really
for you to generate uh your own
primary tumor-derived cell lines and
cell cultures
um as i said that so some
cells just grow for like up to four
weeks but um
we've optimized the media in a way that
the success rate for generation of
stable primary cell lines is
significantly
increased while preserving the
heterogeneity that you observe in the
parental tumor
the cell the tumor media do not
force the cells to grow in an adherent
state or in a suspension state
so this is a cell intrinsic and two
intrinsic feature of different
patient materials and you can observe
both
a tyrant and suspension growth and i
will show
some examples later on it's just
important to know that
if you don't see cells attaching this
doesn't mean it didn't work
your tumor cells simply might grow in a
suspension
state and finally you can also generate
3d models so embed the cells and grow
tumorite-like structures or spheroids
um this is also possible using the tumor
max media
so all in all you can generate your own
primary tumor cell lines
and have improved in vitro models that
really
recuperate what you see in a patient
so if you want to use the media it's
it's really easy as i said you just take
the
fraction or the material that you want
to start the culture with
if you have a single cell suspension we
recommend to
plate 200 000 cells per square
centimeter
and yes they are incubated at 37 degrees
as for also other media of course
at five to the seven point five percent
co2
uh once you've plated the cells you
should change the media every three to
four
three to four days or um of course when
the cells start consuming a lot of
medium also
earlier when it turns yellowish to
support the cells with
fresh growth factors and more nutrients
and once the cells reach a confluency of
80 to 90 percent
you might have some fibroblasts in there
that could grow
you should first remove them and let the
tumor cells sit and
also grow more if you have
80 to 90 percent confluent tumor cells
that would be the time when you passage
them and reseed them into a new vessel
for example a bigger vessel if you want
to expand them or
start your in vitro essays
as i pointed out earlier
this is the basic workflow that you use
to just you know grow the cells and
supply them with new nutrients and
passage them
but you can grow them from different
from different
starting materials and i'd like to
stress this point because this is quite
important as you will see on the next
slide so um
again you can use the transportation
medium by just uh spinning down whatever
you have after
the tumor biopsies have been shipped to
your site
and grow cells from there you can also
if you prefer explan cultures we've seen
that
instead of just you know cutting a piece
of the tissue
and putting it in a dish we've seen that
some kind of pre-treatment or a
treatment with the enzymes we have in
other
tumor dissociation kits is very
beneficial so the
cells really grow much more efficient
out of the pieces that have seen enzyme
before
then of course tumor digest is also a
good starting material
especially since this is single cell
suspensions where you can do cell
counting
and really play it define numbers of
cells if you do phenotyping you also
know the composition of the cells that
you played
so this is an ideal starting material
and
also good to know what you are actually
putting into culture
and then of course if you are only
interested in certain subpopulations
from tumor tissues
this might be simply all tumor cells um
you can use either this negative
enrichment that i showed so
you recover label free cells or for
carcinoma you can
use epchem microbeads or isolating all
carcinoma cells
or you can also of course go for more
specific subpopulations
cd4 t4 positive or hdr5 positive
cancer stem cell like cells so this is
all possible
and if you have the opportunity you
should also
not focus on only one of these options
that you have but
plate cells from different fractions or
from different materials in order to
enhance your
success rate for cell lines or their
cultures
now um here's an example of
pancreatic xenografts that we played it
and here you exactly see these different
starting materials that you can use so
this is tumor digest so
just what you recover after the tumor
dissociation a single cell suspension
that you can
count and play it in a more defined way
we've isolated two more cells so this
fraction doesn't contain any
fibroblasts or endothelial cells also on
and finally we've also tested x-plant
cultures
and as you can see from the pictures
already for the tumor digest we saw that
most of the fibroblasts within the tumor
sample
attached but we hardly saw any tumor
cells
the most successful way for this very
patient material was
the isolation of tumor cells and growing
highly pure tumor cells
and also the explant cultures so this is
an area where we moved
we removed the piece to see whether
cells attached uh also here you see that
we
we hardly have any any tumor cells
so here comes the example from another
patient xenograft
that we also took three different
fractions of
again the two more digest here hardly
any cells only some
fibroblasts now isolated tumor cells and
in this case you also do not really see
attachment of cells
but then when you look at the the cells
that grew out of
[Music]
tissue pieces you really see that you
have nice colonies of
tumor cells and this is just to point
out
the material that you are that you will
be more
successful with this is also a feature
that is um
two more or patient specific and that's
why we would always recommend if
possible to plate
material from different fractions within
the workflow uh to make sure that you
end up with tumor cell cultures and two
muscle lines
i mentioned that the tumor max media do
not force the cells to grow
in a specific state and what you can see
here is
early passage cultures and a late cell
saline from
primary human pancreatic cancer so not
xenotransplanted but directly derived
from the
patient biopsy and when you look at the
earlier passage
the cells from these two examples are
from the very same patient so
you see that uh ethereum cells and
colonies attach and nicely
grow and expand during the early passage
you see some fibroblasts here
that we got rid of in the late passage
and we ended up with
an adherent saline from this patient but
at the same time during very early
phases of the culture we saw that
um there were always some some cells and
some some spheres in the supernatant of
this cell culture so at one point we
decided to
separate them so grow the ethereal cells
exclusively adherent
and then transfer the supernatant to a
new vessel and as you can see here
there were some spheres that formed and
later on
you could really passage them several
times and they would always although
these were not ultra low attachment
plates
they always formed these spheroids and
grew as a suspension cell line that we
ended up with
another option that you have and this is
primary human
colon cancer you can embed the cells in
in matrix gel for example or another ecm
and grow two moroids or more spheroid
light cultures and again you see the
early passage cells up here
um here's a quite big colony or a big
tumoroid and you see that there are
still some
small cells around
once you passage the cells for several
times you see that
they really grow as tumoroids and these
single cells more or less disappear and
you have a 3d model that you can do
more advanced testing with
this is just another example for the
that should show that
it's really an intrinsic feature of the
cells whether they grow as 2d cells
or you can also cultivate them as 3d
cells
this is a colon can succinograft and
we just plated the cells and saw nice
colonies after a while
but always saw these these cells that
were floating around
so um when we had the cells
sitting there for um longest time
we realized that they really always also
tended to
release cells from the tyrion cultures
to the supernatant
so we just decided to try and take some
of the cells also
harvest the whole cell line with trypsin
generate single cells and then grow them
on ultra low
attachment plate and for this very
material we saw that on
ultra low attachment plate a nice
suspension cell line was generated
and we could also propagate them as
a real suspension cell line that formed
spheroid-like like structures so
whenever you see some floating cells in
your um in your cultures or
in your cell lines don't be frustrated
they might just want to
grow as a suspension cells so you can at
this
point just try to take the supernatant
transfer them to ultra low attachment
place
or embed them in ecm and you will see
that in some
or in quite many cases they will also
grow as
3d structures either as spheroids or as
more complex tumorites that might show
some
some polarization of cells for example
another quite handy thing that we
realized
um during the generation of different
cell lines
um it's that you can also use
rokinase inhibitors to enhance the
plating of cells so uh the top picture
shows cells that we just um
put into culture so it's it was um at
this point already an
ethereal cell lines and these cells we
just thought
so they were cryopreserved we wanted to
put them back in culture
and we observed many times that only
really few cells
attached and grew so we decided to test
organize inhibitors in this case the y
compound
and as you can see here uh the the
plating efficiency of the cells is much
uh better and you see that the cells
really played and
or directly start growing so this is
something you should consider either
during early passages of your
cell cultures so um for example when you
played
directly after you recovered the cells
from the biopsies
and plate them you can add rock
inhibitors but also
during the let's say up to passage five
it's quite handy
and also when you put the cells back in
culture after you cry preserve them this
can be
really helpful and handy
another thing that might enhance the
plating of cells is the addition of
serum
so the tumor media are theorem free to
have defined media
but for example when you have cool
cultures or
something like that you might want to
add serum and
this will enhance uh plating or can
enhance plating of the tumor cells
you see cells ovarian tumor cells plated
here in the top picture
and this approach didn't contain any
serum and you see nice
and pure tumor cell culture when you add
serum the tumor cells will still grow as
you see in the
bottom picture here but serum
will of course really support the growth
of fibroblasts so as you can see here
there are lots of fibroblasts all over
the culture so
with the addition of serum you should be
quite quite careful
because this will support fibroblasts
and then they can really
efficiently grow in your cultures
we have now some some so to say
applications for the tumor max media and
the first thing
um i'd like to share with you is um the
the heterogeneity of cells that you
have um in the tumor tissue is really
preserved when you generate
cell lines using tumor max media so you
see h e stains from
[Music]
sections of primary tumor tissues
it's for different tumor materials and
this is really derived from the
from the patient so you see um some
stromal cells
you see two more cells growing here and
for this patient you see some assist
like
structures this patient has less and
you'll see more
mixture with with so not really clear
stromal and tumor cell parts and
here you don't have any cysts and it
looks quite different
so um of course when you now take a
piece of this
tumor biopsy and implant it into a mouse
you have a patient you have stenographed
which will resemble um the
the patient two more so because you
basically
um graft um a piece of tissue so you
have the tissue
architecture in there um within the
first passages
on mice um the stromal cells might be
replaced by the host cells
but the tissue architecture will look
quite similar to the patient wall
um we've then derived cell lines from
those patient tumors you can see in the
pictures here
these are different tumors but um they
look different in vitro but you can't
really
uh conclude um from the pictures of the
cultures what
the patient tumor might have looked like
but the important part
when you now take these cells harvest
them and implant them back into
a mouse you will see a tumor that
closely resembles what you've seen in
the patient so
the first two more again form these
cysts and you see
in this case now a little bit reduced
but the stromal parts here
whereas the last tumor for example
doesn't show any cyst-like structures
but um although they have been in vitro
for some while they still
look like they looked in the patient
when you bring them back into
uh host environment where they have
a way they can be attached to vessels
and start growing
solid to more and this is in contrast to
what you will see when you use classical
or traditional saline so
this is a xenograft model um derived
from punk one cells or pancreatic cancer
cell line that is that is widely used
and it basically you see a mass of
homogeneous uh pancreatic tumor cells
just growing in the mouse and all the
tissue architecture is basically lost or
does not
resemble what you see in patients so
this is a really nice way to expand
tumor cells in vitro because it's easy
and inexpensive
but once you want to study something um
in
in vivo in a more complex setting uh you
can
inject those cell lines and you will
have a
xenograft tumor that really resembles
what you saw in the patient in the
first place
um so i've told you that the cell lines
can be grown over
several passages and they will also
still resemble the tumor that they were
derived from
but another really important feature is
that these airlines are also
genetically uh stable so we've performed
gene expression profiling from early
stage
saline so these are three different
pancreatic cancer
cell lines and we've used the the early
stage which was uh passage five and uh
compared it to late passage science this
was
passage 15 and when you look at the gene
expression profiles you see that you
have a really high correlation between
the early passage and the late passage
which means that during the course of
expanding them in vitro and you know
maybe freezing them
putting them back in culture they do not
acquire a high
amount of different mutations but stay
stable and
do not really change a lot we tested the
same
for xenograft versus initial
so the xenograft that was derived from a
saline versus the initial patient tumor
so you see the patient tumor up here
and compared to the cell and derived
xenograft
and also here you say that you have
really high
correlations between the patient tumor
and the cell in derived tumor
which again shows that the patient's
specific features are
kept during in vitro passaging but then
also when you generate an in vivo
model from those allies
and then something that you also quite
frequently study is
of course the marker expression for
example by flow you see here an example
of ovarian cancers we looked at cd44 and
cd25
and you see the expression pattern in
the
patient xenograph two more you see only
a small fraction of
cd24 cd44 double positive cells
obviously
really low when you put the cells so
dissociate the tumor take them into
culture and generate a seller and that
will be passage over several
times and you check again for those two
markers
you see an enrichment for the double
positive cells which
might point to some kind of
selection or something like that however
when you take the saline and put it back
into a mouse and grow it as as a tissue
you will see that it will resemble um
what what you've seen in the first place
so
only a minor fraction of double positive
cells with most
most of the cells only expressing c44
but not cd24
so this shows that you do not
necessarily select for
single clones that might have a another
expression
pattern what you observe in the cell
line state is rather an adaption to the
in vitro environment which will be
reverted once you put it back into an
in vivo setting so you do not really
introduce a bias it's just a regulation
that you will observe
in vitro
so this already brings me to the to the
summary
so i fall i hope that i've been able to
show you that we have an
optimized workflow with different steps
starting with tumor dissociation which
can be nicely optim
optimized and also automated using the
gentlemax and our
optimized tumor dissociation kits
when you want to selecting specific
subpopulations or just get rid of
non-tumor cells
you can easily and quickly just use max
technology to purify
tumor cells or also select for a certain
setup of interest and
this is something i didn't really go
into detail
of course you can use max technology
when you have a
pyramid primary tumor or also a
xenograph you can isolate two more cells
you can
isolate stromal cells and generate co
cultures and different
specific ratios that you want and study
different
co culture models and finally using the
tumor max media which do not contain
serum
you can now without having to optimize
the
addition of growth factors or cytokines
or whatever you can
for specific tumor cell types generate
your own primary cell lines
um you have as you can generate first of
all
primary cultures so you have a time
window of up to four
weeks to perform in vitro testing from
those
you will get some stable cell lines that
can be passaged and
expanded in vitro and
these cell lines can also be used to
generate in vivo models which will
closely resemble
patient tumors and the patient tumor
heterogeneity
vivo to do more advanced and more
complex testing in in different settings
or whatever you want
to do with vivo models
the data that i've shared of course are
not all generated by me alone
i have to thank my the whole group of my
supervisor dr olaf hart
so this is him and all the people
most specifically uh anna uh lena
and alina who've helped me to
develop and optimize the media the
cultural conditions and
have test multiple things um other
with any colleagues like andreas posio
or vita
and also quite importantly some of the
data are also generated by
our collaboration partner andreas trump
and martin sprick
from high stem without whom this or the
development of those media would not
have been impossible
you